[Musique]
havas défense en pensylvanie des scouts
du monde entier montrent leur temps sur
un terrain qui est l'un des sanctuaires
de l'indépendance nationale aux états
unis et c'est pour les scouts américains
leur deuxième jamboree à l'occasion
duquel ils sont les autres d'autres
scouts représentant 18 nations
[Musique]
et
ils viennent de tous les états
d'amérique depuis canada dix membres
d'angleterre de france de hollande
d'allemagne d'autriche de suède et
d'italie de cuba du mexique de colombie
du venezuela du brésil d'israël des
indes du pakistan et des philippines
[Musique]
le scoutisme connaît pas de frontières
ces jeunes garçons donnent à leurs aînés
un magnifique exemple de fraternité en
vivant et en jouant ensemble avec tant
d'enthousiasmé de simplicité
[Musique]
en 1947 à -100 france les scouts avaient
célébré ce qui fut peut-être un exemple
plus expressif encore de l'union de la
jeunesse leur sixième jubilé mondiale
qui vit représenté 36 nations de cinq
continents
[Musique]
le président auriol saluant tous ces
jeunes dur en plein accord
27000 garçons le défilèrent dans un
stade qu'ils avaient construit de leurs
propres mains défilant d'abord nation
par nation il se groupèrent ensuite en
un geste symbolisant la fraternité
universelle
la jeunesse était sur la bonne voie
après cette visite en france les scouts
américains se firent une fête plus
grande encore à l'anticipation de leur
jubilé de 1950
le grand jour tant attendu et pour
lequel ces garçons de 12 ans et plus
avaient fait leur économie est enfin
arrivé savoir se débrouiller est une loi
scoute aussi chaque troupe
apporte-t-elle son matériel de
campements et monte ça le tente à la
place qui lui est affecté
[Musique]
le temps est partante les scouts
établissent le plus grand rassemblement
de jeunesse jamais réalisé dans
l'hémisphère ouest
[Musique]
les troupes venues de pays lointains ont
apporté le matériel nécessaire à recréer
l'atmosphère de leur pays
[Musique]
non
ces scouts de derrière le rideau de fer
au nord par cet écriteau ceux des leurs
qui victimes du communisme peut-être ici
c'est la vraie ville quand le chacun est
prompt à répondre à l'appel et la
propreté
[Musique]
chacun s'adonne aux travaux du camp
chaque troupe effectue son propre
nettoyage et sa propre cuisine on peut
cependant se procurer des tickets pour
les friandises supplémentaires que l'on
peut obtenir dans les cantines de jean
doré city
[Musique]
les scouts anglais prépare le thé qu'ils
partageront ensuite à l'avant et quand
on apprécie la cuisine des autres une
compréhension totale est en bonne voie
les pastèques du sud des états unis sont
très appréciés de tous
[Musique]
le choeur est de l'inde est suivi par
des gâteaux et des glaces d'américaines
l'appétit d'un garçon en bonne santé ne
se limite pas aux plats favoris de ces
français
[Musique]
l'heure du thé est aussi celle des
nations unies et c'est une session où
sont présentes bonne volonté mutuelle
est parfaite compréhension ici pas de
veto seulement le désir de se mieux
connaître les différentes idéologies ne
s'affrontent pas mais au contraire en
échange des idées un monde nouveau est
en train de se former
[Musique]
ou que soient les scouts les sports l
exercice figure évidemment au programme
conserver un esprit alerte dans un corps
sain et l'un des bus du scoutisme tous
coup tu dois apprendre à être fort
person lutte avec énergie pour éduquer
leurs muscles selon des règles bien
établies
ce n'est pas tellement une question de
victoire mais plutôt d'entraînement
physique
les courses d'obstacles aussi aidé à
coordonner les esprits et les must
l'emploi du temps du jamboree comprend
aussi bien des exploits sportifs que le
maniement des fanions
[Musique]
les scouts étrangers sont eux aussi
passionné des récits des aventures d un
indien et celui ci leur enseigne de
langage des signes de ses ancêtres
[Musique]
le bricolage est en faveur chez les
scouts ses oeuvres artistiques
représentatif de nombreuses nations et
de leur qualité artisanale librement
échangés sont exposés ici l'admiration
de tous
[Musique]
mais le plus grand des plaisirs vient
des échanges de breloques et de tous ces
petits riens que collectionne tous les
enfants du monde la différence de langue
n'est jamais un réel obstacle un bon
échange
[Musique]
ceci est l'image de relations
internationales sur des bases pratiques
et de libre-échange d'articles sans
discussion de tarifs ou de limitations
douanières
[Applaudissements]
les pièces de monnaie de différents pays
étrangers seront conservés en souvenir
de cette magnifique expérience de
jeunesse
les autographes aussi sont un souvenir
mais plus personnelle encore de grandes
amitiés qui se nouent par delà les
océans et les frontières ces jeunes
garçons échangent leurs fuck là une
transnationale bien souvent aidé à
comprendre un peuple et son histoire
l'un des événements les plus marquants
du jamboree vie 47000 scouts se grouper
dans le stade pour se livrer à
l'exécution de leur jeu
[Musique]
des garçons des territoires de l'ouest
des états unis exécute les danses de
tous premiers américains auxquels autant
de connaissances de la science du plein
air ont été empruntés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
à
chaque troupe apporte sa contribution à
l'oeuvre comme une entreprise illustré
par ce panneau où l'on peut lire
fortifions nos libertés
les scouts assemble rapidement des tours
de signalisation et d'observation d'un
incendie ils ont appris non seulement à
vivre dans la forêt mais aussi à la
respecter et à être prêts à la protéger
et à l'entretenir
[Musique]
oh
ici ils sont tous réunis pour entendre
le discours du président sous main la
présence de celui ci malgré les prêts
sans devoir de sa charge montre bien que
la nation toute entière a foi dans la
jeunesse et le futur qu'il représente
monsieur truman et en leur présidente
honoraire les scouts le décor de la
médaille d'argent du buffalo
[Musique]
dans le scoutisme la liberté de religion
n'est pas une théorie politique mais une
réalité et les services de toutes les
églises sont célébrés dans son serment
le scout dit simplement je m'engage à
accomplir de mon mieux mon devoir envers
dieu sa conscience et son seul guide sa
religion ne regarde que lui un garçon ou
un homme est jugé non pas sur ses
opinions religieuses mais sur la qualité
de ses accomplissements
[Musique]
avec un appareil solennelle ayant pour
thème la fraternité mondiale les
drapeaux de toutes les nations libres
forme d'un fonds de grandeur aux
cérémonies marquant la fin du jamboree
[Musique]
ce rassemblement n'est pas autre chose
qu'une assemblée cadette des nations
unies les garçons de cinq continents
vivre ensemble et s'unissent au nom de
la liberté ici la question où est tu
n'es jamais posée mais bien plutôt et
usages etc type est un bon secours
[Musique]
vivant au modèle d' amitiés
internationales
les scouts d'un pays donne tout le monde
un exemple magnifique qu'il serait bon
de suivre
[Musique]